ever since Santos snapped half the
universe out of existence we've been
anxiously awaiting the next films for
Marvel and we cannot wait to meet
Captain Marvel herself here are 10
things we bet you didn't know about brie
Larson the actress who plays the newest
superhero noble warrior heroes besties
sometimes we wish we could just be best
friends with brie Larson but that job is
already taken
free is actually best friends with
another famous actress she met shailene
woodley on the set of the spectacular
now you probably recognize Shailene from
the divergent films apparently when the
two actresses met they had an instant
connection we've had some friends like
that brie was even over at shaylen's
plays for dinner when brie got the call
about starring in short term 12 it's so
awesome to share important events like
that with your BFFs brie has several
other great girlfriends in Hollywood she
is close to Jennifer Lawrence all three
of those actresses play awesome fighting
heroes she's also good friends with
comedian Amy Schumer and actress Emma
Stone she had said some really nice
things about Emma in interviews she
thinks it's great that emma is never
afraid to be herself
we just love seeing strong successful
women supporting each other it's extra
awesome that brie has these great
besties now she has said that she had a
hard time fitting in when she was in
school we're so glad she has a closed
squad these days who are your best
friends tell us about them in the
comments section below
cool hobbies free is one busy actress
she has 4 movies coming out in 2019 Wow
that's alive but she still manages to
make time for her Abhi's and she has
some really interesting ones one of her
main hobbies is typography that's the
art form of designing fonts and
arranging them to look amazing how cool
is that
free also loves video games she's a big
fan of Super Mario Brothers girl same
she also really loved the Metroid game
series she has said she would love to
play their lead character the games are
ever adapted into a movie
what else does BRE like to do in her
free time well she's always down for
some karaoke her go-to karaoke song is
burned by Usher do you think free likes
to go out and sing karaoke with Shailene
and the gang that's a yes-or-no question
yes
girls night he also has one other really
unique hobby this one just proves that
she's super smart she's really into my
ecology that is the study of wait for it
fungus grows but she thinks they're
super interesting we'll take your word
for it Bri we wonder if that has
anything to do with the Mushroom Kingdom
from Super Mario Brothers Bree
definitely has a wide variety of
interests rock and roll love story we
know what it's like to crush on a rock
star we have probably all pinned a
poster of a singer to our wall at some
point but brie actually got to meet and
fall in love with a rock star lucky brie
began dating Alex Greenwald way back in
2013 Alex is the lead singer of the band
Phantom Planet and they were seriously
goals
Alex escorted Breed to several award
ceremonies she thanked him in her
acceptance speech at the Oscars they got
engaged back in 2016 and we thought they
would last forever but the wedding never
came brie has been really busy after all
and they managed to keep the details of
their relationship really private that's
no small task in Hollywood brie has
called Alex her best friend in
interviews it's so important to think of
your partner like that
sadly brie and Alex have recently called
off their engagement the statement from
their publicist said that they're taking
a step back from being engaged but they
also said the two are still close
we hope it all works out for the best no
matter what they decide
hold the meet please have you ever
looked at an animal and just thought
they were too cute to eat well so have
lots of other people veganism is the
type of vegetarianism that involves not
eating any animal products that means
that you can't eat milk cheese eggs and
even honey brie Larson is one of many
actresses who eats vegan she does it for
health reasons but also because she
cares a lot about animals short answer
being vegan just makes you better
in fact being vegan is one of the things
that brie and shailene woodley bonded
over
they're both outspoken about animal
cruelty we aren't here to tell you
what's right or wrong but we do think
it's great that brie can stand up for
her beliefs stage name brie Larson has
one of those names that is easy to
remember but also unique but did you
know that brie Larson is not her real
name
she chose an easier name to pronounce
and remember her real name is brie on
Sidonie the song years that's a mouthful
it's a French name and most of her fans
don't speak French brie is short for
Brienne where did the name Larson come
from it turns out that there are two
reasons that she chose the last name
Larson first Larson was the maiden name
of her maternal great-grandmother that
way she was able to keep a family name
the second reason is something way cuter
she told Jimmy Fallon on The Tonight
Show that it had to do with a toy do you
remember the American Girl dolls Bree
had one as a child the doll she had was
named Kirsten Larson's
Kirsten Larson was one of the first
historic American Girl dolls she was the
one who was a pioneer we loved her
Kirsten doll so much that she took her
last name have you ever loved a toys
that much we think Bree picked an
awesome stage name and she had two
really great reasons for choosing it
finally out of PE sometimes school is
great sometimes it's just not a lot of
times we end up with a class that we
don't enjoy and we don't get along with
every teacher but have you ever disliked
a class so much that you wrote a whole
album about it brie Larson did that's
right brie is also a singer she released
her first album back in 2004 when she
was just a teenager in her album is
about something very relatable she hated
her PE class your school might call it
physical education or gym class brie has
said her PE teacher made her miserable
every day we know PE is not everyone's
favorite class but this sounds terrible
brie was so excited about finally being
done with that class she named her first
album finally out of PE and she
dedicated it to her PE teacher if you
think that's cool just wait till you
hear what she did the next year she got
to go on tour with Jesse McCartney he
was such a teen heartthrob back then
brie also got to sing in the movie
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world she blade
the rock star and V Adams she's got a
really great voice and she continues to
sing occasionally we wonder if she'll
get to sing in any upcoming movies does
Captain Marvel sing that's not her only
Talent stay tuned to find out what else
free Larson can do parlez-vous francais
we already told you that Brie's real
name is Brianna Sidonie Dassin yet it's
a super French name and that's because
Brie's family is french-canadian Brie's
paternal grandparents were from Canada
her mom's side of the family was based
in California although brie was born in
Sacramento California she grew up
speaking French it's her first language
she learned English later as a child but
the older she got the more English she
spoke she has said that her French
skills have faded some but her family
still speaks it and she's still fluent
in both languages Brie's parents were
chiropractors who ran a practice
together but they divorced when she was
young she moved to Los Angeles with her
mom and little sister Bree started out
homeschooled but her parents recognized
that she had a love for acting and she
was accepted into the American
Conservatory for theater at only six
years old
early star Los Angeles is definitely the
place to be if you want to start acting
brie had several opportunities when she
was young because she was so talented
her first professional acting roles were
sketches on The Tonight Show with Jay
Leno know that's Jimmy Fallon Jay Leno
ran the show for a long time starting in
the early 90s after that she got a few
guest roles on television shows
followed by tiny roles in movies but she
moved up the ladder of success really
fast she got her first major role on the
show
raising dad in 2001 she was just 12
years old then she got a role on the
Disney Channel Original Movie right on
track she continued to act while she was
working on her album she also got a
major role on the TV show the United
States of Tara then Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world was released when she was 20
and that launched her into success
basically you can't win this fight so
you're gonna have to give up on this
girl because Todd's gonna kill you her
roles became a lot bigger after that
brie is only 29 at the time of this
video but she has been acting for over
two decades
can you believe it girl power it's not
always easy to be a woman in Hollywood
and brie Larson is very outspoken about
what women deal with in the
entertainment industry brie Larson made
waves when she presented Casey Affleck
with his Oscar in 2016 the actor was the
center of some major controversies about
being really inappropriate with women
brie handed him his Oscar but she did
not smile or clap many women applauded
her for not condoning his behavior she
didn't make a huge deal about it though
she said her actions speak for
themselves she handled her activism for
women with total class in 2017 she took
her activism a step further brie had
been associated with the nonprofit
organization Cinna family this
entertainment company showed movies at
an old theater and raised funds for
various humanitarian work but then two
of the board members were accused of the
same type of things that Casey Affleck
and many other men were Bree stopped
supporting Cinna family the organization
has now shut down completely she did not
want to align herself with things that
she did not believe in we think it's
awesome that brie is so good about
standing up for her beliefs
she also chooses to let her actions
speak louder than words
you go girl Jane of all trades it's
clear that brie Larson is one talented
actress she's won an Oscar after all and
she has also had major success as a
musician but brie has done so so much
more
brie actually considered quitting acting
the film industry can be really
stressful she was having trouble getting
the role she wanted so she tried her
hand at some other options but
ultimately she found her way back to
acting and we're so glad she did and she
does more than just act in movies in
2017 she made her directorial debut with
the movie unicorn store the movie was
shown at some film festivals but it
officially comes out in April of 2019
it's about a woman who gets a mysterious
invitation to fulfill her childhood
dreams brie also stars in it along with
her Marvel co-star samuel l.jackson brie
has also written and directed two short
films is there anything she can't do
we're so excited to see brie as the
superhero Captain Marvel she's the first
female superhero to get their own MCU
movie
and we are pumped see her in Captain
Marvel and Avengers and games this
spring what's your favorite Marvel movie
so far let us know in the comments below
and that's it for the 10 things we bet
you didn't know about free Larsson
thanks for watching and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button for more
awesome videos see you next time
[Music]